hey friends I'm Jason Silva and one of
the most I think exciting Trends
happening in the world today is what
they call the rise of the remote worker
the rise of the digital Nomad it's a
technologically enabled Revolution that
is allowing increasingly a new
generation of worker to do their thing
from abroad to remain productive thanks
to the power of digital devices and
wireless technology to remain productive
from exotic places transcending The Silo
of the office you know the the slow
death of a morning commute that robs
your soul that saps your soul of
Vitality and making it so that this
whole new generation of worker is
realizing hey I can work from Iceland I
can work from Mallorca I can work from
Copenhagen or Amsterdam or Tokyo I can
be productive I can make a living I can
meet other digital Nomads I can fuel my
Wanderlust this is possible this is a
thing this is Liberation and this is the
remote work Revolution the rise of the
digital Nomad but as with all
transformations like as with all
leapings into the unknown we need a
safety net right and this is where I'm
particularly excited by the work of a
company that I've become kind of
enamored with they're called Safety wing
and safety Wing is building an
infrastructure and a safety net for
remote workers and digital Nomads to
have access to basic Services outside
their home country like travel medical
insurance and a health insurance for
companies and individuals so what the
safety net provides of course is peace
of mind to those people that are
increasingly digitally Savvy and working
from places like Bali in between surf
sessions being super productive if
something happens they got that dialed
and it's all thanks to safety with which
is amazing but they're Ambitions friends
go even higher safety Wings goal is to
create a a country on the internet
potentially with its own passport
creating a borderless Utopia where a
digitally empowered digital Nomad and
remote worker a 21st century figure of
sorts has a whole infrastructure and
safety net built around them for them to
soar and gallivant across the planet so
there is poetry in this idea like the
rise of transatlantic travel you know
it's like a new possibility space opens
up for a new generation of people to
reimagine what their lives can be
instead of working a job they hate until
one day they have enough money to retire
it's like no man I'm in my 20s 30s 40s
50s whatever I can go sail around the
world while starting my startup from my
laptop with a satellite phone whatever
it is the world is changing and safety
went it's like a partner in this
Revolution and and for that I salute
them and and and I remain excited that
they are a stepping stone towards a new
world where all of us empowered by these
Technologies and our creativity redefine
what it means to work and redefine what
it means to play Because as they say a
true master in The Art of Living cannot
tell the difference between their work
and their play so let's do this let's
get out there let's chase the sunset and
bring on the remote work Revolution the
rise of the digital Nomad and the
infrastructure and safety net that will
free the brave Reckless gods that live
within us as D.H Lawrence said cheers
foreign